okay this frigging guy hey come watch a
live
birth this is like the coolest clip for
people like us it's so minimal
doing like the least amount of work for
the maximum amount of output so do you
guys have any idea what programs he used
for this
this episode is brought to you by
squarespace stick around to the end to
see how you can save 10
off your first domain hey what's up
everybody welcome back to another
episode of vfx
artist react i'm actually not sure if
this is dfx-rs react or cg
artist reaction people react we are
joined here by the
notorious digital artist beeple so
beetle here
also known as mike he creates a work of
art every single day
so i mostly use cinema 4d with octane
renderer
i use a lot of pre-made models from
turbo squid
to kit bash 3d real displacement
textures game textures my workflow is a
lot like
kid playing with toys and breaking them
apart and putting them together and
setting up a scene and then sort of like
taking a picture and it allows me to
build pictures that are
fairly complex very fast so we want to
sit down and do a special version of
this show
we're not going to be focusing on visual
effects movies we'll be focusing on some
crazy
cg art videos stuff that you've probably
never seen before is hopefully gonna
blow your mind it's gonna be a little
weird it's gonna be a little wacky but
it's definitely gonna be fresh
buckle up
this first clip is by an artist named
igor it's wacky and crazy have fun
this is great imagine dancing that hard
like at a wedding
[Music]
the edit is super good the destruction
sims like
everything like there's so much like
look at that it's oh my god it's so good
[Music]
oh my god i love that treasure
[Music]
there's so many shots in it too that was
not a small amount of work and some of
them are quite complex yeah you usually
don't see like complex physical
simulations and special effects
in like a wacky crazy surrealist
music video what i'm always looking for
is things that are like i've never seen
something like that before
the other thing is when i can see for
sure that this took like a crapload of
work
yeah like little just like quick shots
like that this like a two second shot
that took like a day like that's not
nothing how often are you
watching crazy stuff like this and
getting inspired by this stuff or is it
more like
you just kind of have a database of
stuff in your head that you're already
going for
no i definitely would say i get you know
inspired by stuff like this and it might
just be a small moment or
a shape or a shot or you know a
composition you know it could be a bunch
of different
small things like that i mean that
doesn't look that far from something
that i would do
not that far off let's be honest
david o'reilly is a pretty unique
animator 3d artist this
won't seem like a sensible video but it
has impact and i kind of want to talk
about that
if you're doing something abstract how
do you find the art in an abstraction
what can make an abstract work
give you an emotion and other abstract
work doesn't do anything for you
the two things just exactly what i said
about that other video
i can tell this took a buttload of time
and two it's like i've never seen that
before
it just looks very tight and the
characters are super well designed and
interesting and fresh to me it just
seemed like very ahead of its time
you know you've talked about mood and
it's one of those things that kind of
glides by because you're focused on the
crazy subject of this piece but you know
the crashed world war ii bombers
slightly sticking out of the fog
the nazi symbology combined with the old
walt disney stuff the strobe lights
flickering on and off all over the place
that are pretty artfully placed and then
the only color
being here wait there's color there yeah
wait the cat's nose is nice
i don't see the eyes okay you're fired
you just got fired bro got a fired
[Laughter]
i like how he intentionally does low
frame rate animations too because you
can render out cg animation at whatever
frame rate you want you know it's like
why not render out at 60 frames per
second or 30 frames per second but he
intentionally does like a 12
frames per second look which gives it
almost like a stop-motion claymation tan
animation feel disconnects it a little
bit from reality and makes it feel more
like an animation
that's the like subtle things in his
craft the animation
is stylized but also quite realistic
like i don't know a lot of context about
this one
i somehow stumbled across it on youtube
when it had like a thousand views
and you watch it and like i cannot find
the little line where like real ends and
cg begins
[Music]
freaking creeping me out just wait
that's so disgusting right yeah but it's
beautiful at the same time
oh i don't even know how they're doing
this is it cg
i can't i literally can't quite tell i
can guess but okay
god damn this freaking guy hey come
watch a live
birth yeah there's no cg here this is
just me being born
goddamnit guy why would you show me this
no dude this is so good yeah what the
hell how does this only have 50 000
views this is freaking insane who is
that
martin dethora oh my god it's just done
so well like you're saying so subtle and
the comping
was just like so on point i think the
decision to make it black and white
is really really great here because it
just it makes all the cg blends so much
better but also yeah it allows you to
really focus on the light values and
craft your frame
without having to worry about color you
just look at can i read these
silhouettes and these shapes perfectly
and you do with everything here
yeah yeah you can see specular like
bumps that kind of like okay that's
slimy you're like oh that's like hairy
what the
it is just so good
raul marks i think he's got one or two
emmys he did this amazing amazing piece
and semi-permanent titles like 2015.
this is all done by him in like a month
or two
that looks amazing
so sick the lighting is nuts yeah it's
so
good it's so good the compositions are
so
good so on point the scale
like that's a sense of scale so good
just the tiniest little speck it takes a
lot of guts to like scale your image
down
it's like that's that pixel it's like
you'll still be able to see him
[Applause]
oh my god yeah and then he gave away
this model so you've seen that model
this model specifically in hundreds of
things
i love that lighting the black and white
like super sharp
lighting looks so good the hardest thing
about like lighting is like
you'll think in your mind i'll light up
the silhouette of this thing and then
you go and you start putting lights in
your scene it's like oh but that thing
casts a shadow over here if i put a
light over here it makes a reflection
over there
and you start to wonder like how do you
get this amazingly clear clean lighting
that like makes my silhouettes pop
it just takes like so much time and
craft to be able to know where to put
your lights
where to put your flags which are things
that block light and
how to perfectly describe the shape
of the objects in your scene with your
lights and flags
it's freaking nuts he has definitely
been super super big like inspiration
just insane so as you can tell we're
doing things a little bit differently
for this episode of vfx artists react
and it's part of doing things
differently
it's not just me and clint on the couch
we're actually swapping out some of the
other team here
so they also have some cool art videos
so clinton you're up next who do you
want to be your partner
ren sam or myself i think i'm going to
call sam down okay so it turns out sam
and i are the same person check this out
oh snap okay
like is that painful no it's momentary
oh for sure
anyways so what were we saying uh
actually here this is
i'm gonna pull some clips so if you
don't mind getting in the middle yeah
i'll just take this
now mike the first clip i got for you
it's called going to the store and i
know you've seen this one
[Music]
so good dude those shots are so good
that freaking hip shelf it's so gross
the fact that the skin shader looks so
real is like the best part and it's comp
so freaking well like the attention to
detail is there
that is like a big part of the joke it's
this weird thing but you put
so much time into the job yeah it's to
me where it you know you appreciate it
on another level
it's beautiful how there's a place for
this in our world i know right
as tools sort of become available you
just look at like a video like this
the amount of things in there that we
take for granted now
were not possible 20 years ago it's
getting crazier and crazier because like
people can just do everything themselves
these days yeah
i definitely think the tools present new
possibilities that just would not be
there before
it's kind of a pretty huge deal because
we've seen that like in everything from
like visual effects to like
editing you could make a cg image on
your home computer before you could edit
a video on it
the processing power for video was still
way higher than hey i need to make some
wireframes it's actually pretty great
segue to a clip i want to show you guys
too
good morning this is your wake-up call
this movie is more relevant than ever
because it takes place in 2021 this is
like
the coolest clip for people like us
we're into like cg stuff
and vr and this movie did it over what
is it 25 years ago
here it is let's see how it holds up to
test the time
welcome to brt online so we're watching
this and it's like okay this is goofy
old movie graphics you know it's early
90s
cg rendering and what makes this special
is they did all this stuff on home pcs
really they weren't using like big
workstations from like huge vfx houses
it's basically one of the first films
where
desktop rendered 3d was put in a movie
that's great and that's crazy when you
look back at like the lawnmower man
stuff
or even jurassic park you know like if
that's not a computer you can just go
and buy oh that's like
a freaking ilm box i could crash you
from here man
wipe out your entire board
it's funny how some of it is actually
it's like oh it looks so
dumb but some of it's actually pretty
good yeah it's pretty cool
yeah it's you know it's got all your
funny 90s trophy design
and stuff but knowing that process that
goes into it it's like a prototype
version of 3d studio max probably
or maybe some c40s in there i'm not
totally sure that's awesome
i could only imagine like
troubleshooting that stuff
way back in the day they're like oh how
do i get the spline to
to be like you know moved and positioned
and now it's like
the problems we're dealing with today
are like how can i get my boobs looking
sweeter
no but but really though for real
oh yeah like the contrast is hilarious
dude that's great it's been great that
was our last corridor reaction
episode thank you guys for watching yeah
that's a wrap on this series
[Laughter]
it's great all right we have an
emergency message for you which is why
we're taking the tiny emergency react
couch
this wednesday we have a auction an nft
auction with defaults for charity it's
gonna be super cool there's gonna be an
awesome render challenge video that goes
with it
as well so make sure you watch the video
and check out our makerspace.com
corridor digital account you'll see
some pretty cool stuff up there this
wednesday
for charity it's big let's help some
people makerspace.com
or digital link in the description below
this wednesday with people
it's gonna be crazy yeah somehow we
managed to do an auction with people
we don't get it either it's crazy
this art style is freaking awesome yeah
i like that super boxy projection map
kind of yeah look at that it's like not
even projected properly
[Music]
this is art man wow this is so
good this is super trippy it's so
minimal doing like the least amount of
work for the maximum amount
of output like the color the composition
the lighting
the time consuming part i see in this is
like well everything is made from
scratch
to fit the style but it's also designed
in a very thoughtful way to like fit
into a very specific
nuanced design language like how are we
gonna do spokes oh okay let's just jam
them all together like that
when it comes to cg art you know there's
two goals there's either make something
photo real
or your goal is to make something
expressive if you're going for a sense
of realism
you're not trying to convey an emotion
you're trying to convey
reality and the moment you want to make
it expressive you're like all right well
forget
reality forget what things are supposed
to look like i'm going to
be expressive with it i'm going to use
art to convey something higher
than reality is able to capture this is
like that perfect example
this captures a feeling and an emotion
and like a tone that is
impossible to get when you're doing it
in reality if it was really a story
about a one-eyed cat with a tongue
hanging out
it almost might be unwatchable it would
be a horror movie
all right guys so i'm gonna go summon my
good buddy ren
mike it's been chill i'll see you soon
what just happened
this is it's over the top oh
it's really find a way to take it up a
notch all right i have a clip
that i wanted to show you guys it's from
a very talented company called method
studios and this was just a fun little
music video they threw together
anyone who likes simulations this has
every
possible simulation in it
it's just crazy because it's got that
organic human
motion mixed with like just crazy
physical simulations that are not
physically possible
yeah it's like i feel like there are
three main things going on through all
of this that work really well
one is the motion capture these are
actual dancers performing
and their performances are being
captured live and then the second aspect
are
actual artists going in and creating all
these crazy simulations attached to
these people
and it's reacting to how the person's
moving throughout the scene
and the third stage of all this is the
actual render it looks very realistic
super tight
on the top so do you guys have any idea
what programs he used for this i would
assume it's
mostly houdini that was going to be my
guess as well i think this is houdini
us little c4d boys here we don't have
that power
i think it comes down to the fact that
motion capture
that's been a commodity with a lot of
scarcity for a very very long time
the only way to get animation is yeah
just
which is very hard to do compared to the
suit
just a simple motion like this you know
or some simple dance could take
literally a week to animate or it could
be like
captured within literally minutes yeah
but the flip side of this is that when
you do have to hand animate it like that
you have
so much more intention with every single
move that's why like any cg animated
movie
all of the animation is overly
exaggerated because it is a cartoon and
yeah
every motion has to carry with it a lot
of like intent
guys there's a lot of great clips here
today but
in order to wrap this out i think we're
going to need nico back here
hey i'm back 41 of our viewers aren't
subscribed
and if you're one of those 41 percent
you go to hell
ah you gotta use this one
we're gonna use this one all right
consider subscribing we really
appreciate it
all right so it would be remiss to have
an artist react series without taking a
look at any of
mike's actual work so let's take a look
at your instagram page
[Laughter]
there's videos at the top like bad stuff
bad stuff bad stuff
[Music]
okay it was labeled in all fairness to
me it was labeled bad stuff
and boom you can literally see the
second
that you guys got demonetized
shut her down boys dinner down three
strikes you're out you just got
literally three community freaking
violation strikes
concurrently on top of each other and
this platform is done i don't think i'm
alone when i ask
how do you come up with something like
that like okay what do you mean this
seems
obvious how do you come up with
something like that
you're telling me that was not obvious
to you this is straight
up not child appropriate
i love this one oh yeah oh dude yeah
that jittery pikachu head
like how did you whip this together in a
day this this is like no so these were
not done in a day the every days are
done in a day these are usually done in
probably like two or three days
usually they start as an everyday and
then it's like oh i could animate that
are these like mixamo animations are you
making these animations yourself
and to really quick explain what miximo
is it's basically a stock footage site
for actual animations
yeah it's got tons of different people
dancing people
like falling over falling over yeah
punching yeah
and you can sort of like very you know
quickly and sort of like easily plug
those into
your models and create stuff this one
actually is from
uh arc viz piece of software for
generating crowds
this is probably from mixamo i would say
it's a mix of the
rococo suit mixamo and sort of like hand
animating you know certain things
and then a lot of these have sort of
like simulations on top of that to
simulate the chords
so mike if somebody wanted to make
something quick
what would your advice be to them my
advice would just be
set a timer and set it in five minute
increments and
stick to it and spend a half hour versus
trying to like cram in and like i gotta
learn every single thing about this in
the next like week spacing it out giving
you
like time to process that and really
absorb the information and then
steadily incrementally working over a
long period of time i think is just
such a better way to like learn
something i think it's easy to sort of
get
lost in the weeds on creating especially
if there is no deadline
it makes it hard to just sort of draw a
line in the sand and be like it's done
yeah artists really need constraints so
not only did we get to sit down with
mike to look at some really cool visual
effects we also got to pick his brain
about the whole nft space it's a really
cool opportunity for us to ask him
questions
and i'm sure you'll be very interested
to hear those answers as well subscribe
stay tuned it's a big week it's a big
couple weeks coming up
this episode is brought to you by
squarespace have you ever been
overwhelmed by the idea of making a
website you're like
i should probably get a website but i
don't know the first thing about html
coding well fortunately you don't have
to know
anything about designing a website
because there are award-winning
templates
already there for you to choose from now
let's say you've got a team and you need
a lot of people contributing
to the same website well with multiple
contributors everyone can do exactly
that
you probably also have a bunch of social
media accounts well guess what it's
super easy to cross-post between the two
of them because it all synchronizes very
nicely
and since you're probably running a
business off this website it really
helps to know your audience and with
traffic overview you can see exactly
who's visiting your sites what kind of
page views you're getting
where they're coming from and if you end
up running into problems well they've
got 24
7 support that wins awards as well so
you know they're good
all you gotta do is go to
squarespace.com quarter crew and you
will get 10 off your first domain
thanks for watching i want to see if
people can out show this video
hey
you want to leave a comment below
[Laughter]
oh boy i can't do it
i feel very weird doing it i feel very
weird i'm not i don't have that like
when it's time
to be at victoria's reaction it's time
to go
it's a certain kind of energy and it
doesn't feel
weird when you see it what is up
everybody we are back with a very
exciting episode
but it feels i can't do it
thank you so much for joining us it's
always a pleasure i love the energy that
you bring
it's great i appreciate that man i
appreciate it always super fun to like
hang out with you guys you guys are
you know blowing me away with the stuff
you guys are doing so
thanks fans likewise you can basically
check out all of people's work on
instagram
not suitable for work yeah don't do it
when you're home
alrighty we'll see you guys in the next
one